欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,我们前面已经讲了关于产品优化的一些理论
那么接下来我们要用一个案例来告诉大家
让大家能够更加清晰的知道怎么样去具体的实操
产品优化我们分为三步骤
让你真正掌握产品优化的底层逻辑
快速的解决整个产品的流量的问题
第一个就是筛选产品
我们前面已经说了
我们的四项线优化法
那么都是根据那四个核心的指标去进行筛选产品的
那么我们来看一下我的这个截图
这个截图就是产品参谋里面的一个具体的一个数据
那么我们来看可优化的产品
上面是不是有曝光量, 点击, 循环这几个维度
是不是我们可以进行一个选择
设置对应的数据来进行筛选出产品
筛选出产品之后
我们再根据产品的一个判断跟数据进行优化
那么我们直接来看一下后台吧
比如说我们打开了这个界面之后
是吧
第一步就是先选择数据的时间维度
通常我们优化的产品的时候
通常是按照一周或者是按照月来进行优化的
每周周二进行优化
每月按照月的3到4号进行对产品进行优化
我们不仅仅对这个产品的一些数据维度优化
我们还会对自动车, 除窗等等进行一个综合的优化
那么你看我们这个后台这里不是有个可优化的产品吗
先去筛选出我们要优化的产品
比如说我们刚才讲的根据曝光量跟点击量
这四项线里面去进行优化
这里数据你可以设置的
曝光量比如在多少多少以及点击量在多少
那么你就设置好了之后进行一个筛选
筛选出来下面这里就会有很多产品展示了是吧
通常来说我们在这里设置了数据之后
它展示的产品数量都是非常少的
那么我们只需要对这些产品进行优化就可以了
其他的产品就不要去浪费时间了
那么第二个维度是不是从点击到询盘这个维度
我们还是一样根据四项线去优化就可以了
同时呢我们一定要把这个产品的指标勾选出来
把核心的勾选出来
勾选哪些呢
我们来讲一下比如说你的一个是曝光量一定是要勾的嘛
曝光点击以及循盘元素啊天这四个是必勾的嘛
再加上一个访客或者是说点击率你可以勾也可以不勾
但是这四个维度第一个第二个第三个第四个必选嘛
后面那些你根据实际需求来进行去选择就可以了
因为它是有数量限制的这就是我们筛选产品以及勾选产品指标来进行针对性的优化
我们演示一个案例吧比如说我选择高曝光我选择低点击
单独从这里选你看0点击高曝光是在11到76系统帮我选了
我不需要我自己设置数据那么这个时候下面就会出现产品
出现产品了之后你就根据你勾选的这些数据维度然后去对产品进行优化
因为我们勾选之后我们还要进去看了看产品具体的数据之后
我们就知道怎么优化产品了我把这些区去掉去掉了之后呢
比如说我就到下一个维度高点击低旋盘你可以根据你看旋盘是少了
高点击是2到6说明什么说明系统给我推荐的这个数据是非常的小的
为什么呢一个是因为我选的时间维度少
第二个就是我本身这个店铺他的一个整体的数据就比较长了
所以说这个维度就小你选的周期长或者是说你本身店铺数据非常好的话
这里肯定会推荐的数据更多一点
你要根据店铺的实际情况来去选择就可以了
那么这个就是关于产品优化的具体的实操的步骤那么关于他里面的数据判断这个我们就在这里就不展开讲了
因为我们前面都已经把具体的问题
的方法讲得非常清楚了你只需要按照那个标准去判断就可以了
第三步就是细节方面的优化比如说
我们刚才点的这个产品是在这里是吧
他的产品的综合数据是吧
点击分析之后是不是就进入到了产品更加详细的一个数据的分析
比如说关键词你要看哪些关键词有点击的是不是
来自自动车的他有没有循环有没有tm
他的转化率怎么样你看这些维度在产品360
分析里面打开之后就是这个页面你看这些访客是不是准确的价格怎么样
你的同行都是哪些人他发的产品怎么样他的价格起定量是怎么样
等等这些细分维度你只需要根据我们前面讲的方法
去进行优化就可以了
所以说产品优化其实很简单就是分三步走快速解决产品流量的问题
第一个就是把产品筛选了
第二步就是筛选了之后判断这些数据
再针对一个个产品去优化比如说这里会有很多ABC
第一这几个产品你一个个点击进来分析分析之后你就根据这些数据最后面一步就是调整
调整就可以了嘛
这节课我们就先讲到这里
我希望你多去实践多去操作
这个才能够真正的掌握这种
思路跟方法那么我们下节课讲一个关于
套品逻辑优化